clinquant séries lentes et les années
chez ce concessionnaire de loi donne
dans lanaudière le téléphone ne dérougit
pas ces jours ci des clients ont choisi
d'acheter électrique pour
l'environnement et bombe ayant un rabais
de 5000 $ qui est intéressant aussi la
subvention d'ottawa s'ajoute à celle de
québec
ici on pourrait vendre jusqu'à 100
voitures électriques d'ici juin c'est
vraiment un record le plus de voitures
électriques on a vendu dans un mois
environ soixante dix
outre le prix des visiteurs du salon du
véhicule électrique de montréal explique
ce qui les empêche de prendre le virage
vert c'est le manque de modèles et puis
l'autonomie si les fabricants
s'intéressent à produire des nouveaux
modèles c'est parce qu'il ya un intérêt
d'assaut un intérêt indéniable
le nombre de véhicules électriques dont
la province a pratiquement doublé en
2010 8 par rapport à l'année précédente
à ce rythme on pourrait dépasser la
cible de 100000 véhicules électriques au
québec d'ici 2020 on va peut-être
l'atteindre un peu plus rapidement
d'autant plus que le choix de véhicules
électriques augmentent d'année en année
et plus adaptés finalement la classe
moyenne
si on veut justement à réduire les gaz à
effet de serre ben il ya différents
secteurs dans lesquels faut investir
électrique 15 ont des moyens transports
en est un qui est très important
mais une voiture électrique demeure une
voiture qui crée de la congestion et
dont la production est polluante vaut
mieux prendre le transport en commun ou
le vélo
non j'ai parfois l'impression d'être un
vendeur de charles est très important je
n'ai pas de taux je n'ai jamais eu de
tour je n'en n'aurai jamais mais pour
ceux et celles qui ont besoin d'une
voiture la voiture électrique est
beaucoup plus intéressante
le prochain objectif pour québec est
d'atteindre 1 million de véhicules
électriques d'ici 2030 ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morin